you can only do so much when you're
constantly hit with data points right
where you just you know
i don't know
just the way i'm wired like you have to
take action when you're seeing
statistic after statistic after you know
trend after institutionalized gender
bias like you just
it just paints a story or tells a story
and paints a picture that um
we're being
left out of research we're being
unseen
underserved in the conventional and
frankly any healthcare model
and that the statistics of the women who
are suffering for these hormonal issues
throughout these four decades which
includes not just menstruation but
fertility and perimenopause
that's just a statistic that keeps
growing and i
feel compelled
to do something about it and it's not
just that i feel compelled it's that
also
there's that sort of side of me that's
sort of absorbing all the statistics and
the data but then there's the side of me
as the academic and the researcher who's
looking and saying there's a way out
so
let's acknowledge that there's a
flaw
in the model that we are operating in
around our hormonal health care let's
just acknowledge that which you know
sort of do in the first couple chapters
of the book but then let's just move
forward and here's the correct
information and here's how to do it
and let's expect better
for our health and our health care as
women and the i fundamentally know that
the sort of
uh ripple effect of that for women goes
well beyond uh just what
how it impacts their health you know
short term and long term it's really a
whole life shift
you know just the other day i was doing
a
webinar for moms with teenage daughters
and you know how do you deal with your
daughter's pms right and i said well the
most important thing that you have to do
as a mom if you have a young daughter
start to have a conversation with her at
nine
you know i have a my daughter will be
seven
in the fall
and
you know she already understands some of
these basic things right i've been
educating her in my own way can only
imagine what having me as a mom would be
like if you're right you're a girl
so i you know at nine though you know
we're gonna have a whole conversation
about
you know different biological rhythms
and that for her
you know at a certain age you know
12-ish
what i want the focus to shift from is
not talking about oh you're going to
have this
thing happen around bleeding
just really it isn't serving any purpose
it puts the focus on the wrong thing
that's a part of the story
but unfortunately that part of the story
has been so co-opted by the negative
millennia-old
curse conversation
that
i think we could do better to serve our
young you know women by telling them
instead okay actually around 12 this
whole new biological clock is going to
get activated in your brain and affect
every system of your body
and
it's going to give you huge advantages
in creativity and energy and immunolog
immunological response and everything
else
um but you have to make one key switch
when this happens oh really what's the
switch that i have to make like i'm just
imagining this dialogue between a mom
and a daughter okay well the switches
you go from taking care of yourself the
same way every day
to changing your self-care routine four
times a month and i'll show you how to
do that when the time comes but i just
want you to be prepared that this super
amazing brain body thing is going to
happen to you and it only happens to
girls and how cool is that
if we had that conversation
at nine
and then you know actually giving the
practical
how-to of the cycle sinking method at 12
making that the focus of menstruation
like now here's menstruation
now you have your clock you can set your
timer for self-care to those four phases
start doing it start tracking your
cycles we're doing so you get a 12 year
old girl biohacking
essentially building a positive
relationship with her body
then we just kind of bypass all the
patriarchal wounding and kind of just
quickly get out of what typically
happens at that age which is some form
of trauma right because if you haven't
been prepared for what is going to shift
in your body you can register that in
many different negative ways that
affects your health your psychology and
frankly the trajectory of your life
so it's exciting to think about
um
what could change for women
uh at any age when they figure this out
but especially what could happen when we
sort of really
model this
for the young women in our lives yeah
and give them a different platform
because it's it's the cur it's correct
to do that and it's what young men get
to have access to and we know how how
advantageous that is for them
so they theirs is pretty simple right i
mean i think this is what was
fascinating is fine learning how and i
don't think i mean like micro macro
whatever call it an a similarity like
women are complicated and no i reject
that i'm sorry i reject that you reject
that i reject that phrasing because it's
not true it's not true that is a great
example
of cultural conditioning and accent in
action right
you live in your own body
right the only reason that you would
call it complicated is because you
haven't been given a proper tour
right like if you were to say to me
elisa please
come to my house and go get me the um
sweater that i want
i'd be like oh no that's complicated
which room in the house is it which
drawer is it is it in a closet i don't
know where to go and what to do to do
this that feels complicated and
overwhelming
exactly the same thing if you haven't
been given the blueprint of how your
body works you are making an inaccurate
assumption
that you are complicated which you are
not you are extremely logical and easy
to understand but who's who's telling
you what how it works no one
men are equally complex
as women's biology is right
in a different way they're just it's
just two different patterns
why would we judge one pattern as easier
or more efficient
and one as more complex or complicated
or problematic or mysterious if it only
the only reason we would do that is a
cultural conditioning what the narrative
has been your whole life running in the
background of your life about the
differences between men and women so i
reject that and i challenge any woman
to really start to look at what is that
inner dialogue and that script that
you're running inside of yourself
that has you talking about
what you are
right if you're saying you're
complicated and
problematic and hormones are a burden
that's not true
so it's an opinion who gave you that
opinion
um
i never had that see i i think there are
definitely definitely scripts and um
patterns and
um
you know absolute ways of thinking that
are
just patterns in society
i
i kind of err on the side of sort of
balance
and so like everything has its natural
balance point and so
meaning i do think that women have more
to deal with like guys don't have to
deal with
the four phases through the month they
don't have to they don't deal and now
keep him hang on let me let me let me
get to the good part at the end they
don't deal with that they don't deal
with the you know having a cycle they
don't deal with bearing a child um so on
this side you have more right but you
get more too like it's these are things
that you have to deal with but on the
other side you have
creativity as a potential like deep
creativity deep connection
um uh
understanding recovery and solitude
understanding you know all those
different things and the heightened
potential that is
obtained from maximizing these phases
and then magical things like childbirth
and so i kind of fall on the side that i
think that there's more to deal with
that you get but you get more and so
i would break it down even then too like
just to like the beautiful aspect that
you know women are
amazing beings like we literally are
creation like we are created literally
nothing exists without creation and
that's what we are
well you're not going to have me argue
that point but what i will say is i
would just as i as i share in the book
and as i share all the time when i speak
is that men do have a cycle it just
happens to be 24 hours they do go
through similar phases during the day
i would say it's more challenging for
men because it's happening in a very
compressed fashion
right so they wake up with their testos
they kind of wake up in
their
ludial phase if i had to pick a phase
that they'd wake up in right uh they go
to bed during their menstrual phase they
wake up in their ludial phase it's kind
of a backwards situation
then then there
there's not so much follicular phase
things happening then they're kind of in
the afternoon they're in an ovulatory
social verbal phase right so they have
these
kinds of phases throughout the day the
morning testosterone cortisol surge for
them is um where they're doing their
deep focused high concentration work
where they can build lots of lean muscle
with strength training very similar to
the luteal phase
where they have to feed their body with
more calories
and all of that
then in the afternoon they have their
testosterone cortisol drop
which is why nootropics are really
popular around male biohackers because
they have to compensate for their loss
in like ability to focus mentally
and stamina so this is something they
have to compensate for they do with
caffeine they do with other nootropics
and but it's also why corporate culture
has happy hour around this time because
this is when men have a little bit more
access to their estrogen which makes
them more verbal and social but then
after dinner
they're now
in their lowest phase of hormones which
is exactly what menstruation phase is
the bleeding phase right the lowest
levels of all your hormones they need to
go into the whatever their version of a
man cave is and go to sleep in order for
them to make testosterone for the next
day
so they have a similar cyclical need
and what's interesting is that when you
look at that and you look at
what all the diet and fitness and bio
hacking and success hacking and life
coaching suggestions and trends and
things that we just accept is
universally true they're really actually
all designed to optimize for
that male hormonal cycle that happens in
a 24-hour period
and it's a great technique and it's one
that women should be doing too except we
shouldn't be applying it in a 24-hour
clock because we don't
operate that way in our reproductive
years we have
yes we always have a circadian clock
like men do
throughout our whole lives and children
and old people everybody has a circadian
clock but during puberty we have sort of
this introduction of an infrared and
even a circuit radiant clock where we
have this other cyclical thing happening
in our body that's affecting our brain
our metabolism our immune system our
stress response system
so it is flawed and illogical to apply
the same self-care routine
to an ecosystem that's not the same
every 24 hours if you're in a female
ecosystem if you're in a male ecosystem
that is absolutely correct and optimal
and it's why you would want to
you know stack your calories early in
the day and stack your workouts early in
the day if you're a guy
but if you're a girl
it depends on which phase of the cycle
you're in it's going to dictate how many
calories you have to eat or which
workouts you're going to do
or anything else for that matter so when
people ask me oh lisa what's your
favorite morning routine
i said well it just depends on which
which phase of the cycle we're talking
about right
because even just that even some of
these assumptions that we make that the
ideal wake-up time is 5 a.m
that's actually to optimize uh for what
happens when testosterone is released
into the bloodstream after men produce
that during sleep right so if if they
wake up at five
they're gonna have access to all of this
that's just been released into their
bloodstream along with cortisol they
should get up and take advantage of that
that is not necessarily the case for you
depending on your cycle phase so it's
important for women to navigate this
because if you do
think that that's the ideal
right and you're following those trends
then you start to disrupt
these other rhythms the infrared and the
circuitry and rhythms
and then you start to have symptoms
across the board with your brain
performance with your metabolism with
your immune system with your stress and
anxiety with your reproductive system
right
and it isn't that you need a different
solution for all these problems it's
that you are disrupting your key
biological rhythm
by applying a methodology that's
optimizing a whole different
gender rhythm